[Musique]
je ne fais rien je profite justement de
ne voir rien à faire pour me balader
pour voir des copains parce que pour moi
c'est très important j'ai à peine à
rester tout seul
j'aime bien la notion de pertinence et
jamais ça je crois que c'est toujours
très très créatif de déraisonner comme
ses fantasmes dit ça alors tu vois c'est
la voilà c'est la pièce où je travaille
et je m'amuse à la fois parce que je
trouve que les deux sont assez liés et
que c'est difficile de rentrer dans une
pièce de travail ça mais moi
personnellement ça me coupe l'envi alors
c'est pour ça que je me suis un peu
organiser la vie comme ça avoir tout
sous la main
la musique fait ça si serge gainsbourg
l'homme à tête de chou
[Musique]
lancé quelques livres que j'aime bien
sûr des personnes du spectacle ou du
sport fin des personnalités publiques
alors ça va de borg
d'abord lui aussi fils en passant par
par buster keaton par par michel simon 6
qui m'ont mon acteur préféré qui est le
le cinéma fait tom la caisse qui a
encore il ya une autre sujet de détente
ça pour savoir comment va se passer la
journée
c'est pas mal pas mal s'annonce bien là
c'est bon comme je vous ai dit pars pas
trop officiel parce que j'aime pas les
bureaux moi j'essaye d'écrire des choses
définitives à chaque fois et qu'ils
deviennent de moins en moins parce qu'
on ne fait que bareille pu réécrire
voilà quoi puis des auteurs que j'aime
bien
jules renard enfin te papa de petites
choses
et puis qu'est-ce que je pourrais vous
dire encore bas que j'ai essayé de
m'entourer de deux visages que j'aime
bien comme harold lloyd et puis surtout
charlie chaplin qui
moi un très très grand silence peut-être
le plus grand enfin quelqu'un qui avait
aidé au développement du cinéma qui l'a
inventé j'ai trouvé cette chose là qui
est là
[Musique]
ça évite les allers-retours au café puis
ça me permet un peu de faire des
pronostics sur le film qui sortent d'où
l'on dirait que vous dites est le
première bien se passer ou non suivant
mon score je suis à peu près fixé
j'aime bien bavarde et déraisonné moi
c'est très important je joue michel
ribes qui est l'auteur et le metteur en
scène ne rien ne va plus qui est le type
le film qu'on vient de terminer pas très
longtemps
et puis qui parallèlement à ça travaille
med et les cris des sketches aussi pour
le théâtre pour la seconde voilà moi
l'idée que je voulais proposer c'était
de donc faire un thème un personnage qui
a peur de tout dans la rue et qui a peur
de tout non seulement dans la rue mais
dans les trains et même chez lui et qui
finit par ne plus sortir de chez lui
exactement tellement il a peur et il
préfère avoir peur chez lui plutôt que
peur dans la rue exact mais des kits
médias il a peur
je crois que les skis et ce qui serait
important est marrant c'est que ce que
lui fasse peur aujourd'hui exactement
c'était les gens qui les gens qui font
plus peur aux gens sont des gens ont
très très peur moi ça m'est difficile
comme ouvrez l'oeil qui surveille le
plus c'est le public visage fait
beaucoup de choses tout seul en scène il
me faut pour que j'écoute les gens il
faut vraiment être encore au dessus des
réactions publiques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]